yeah okay
ah okay we're starting 1 minute later
each day and today high-dimensional day
I just kick us off the song from Georgia
Tech he's worked on almost all aspects
of machine learning at this from here
they from kernel methods to deep
learning to nonparametric methods please
search others about embedding ok thank
thanks for everyone for coming when I
think about machine learning algorithms
actually it's more than just algorithm
I'd like to think about is the model
plus the algorithm sometimes if you
appropriately properly design your model
and actually the algorithm is going to
be better ok so essentially when I look
at machine learning algorithms sort of i
roughly categorized machine learning
algorithm the two classes one type of
machine learning type of model algorithm
is going to be this function
approximation approach here and for
instance neural nets and kind of method
belong to this class you take your
inputs you directly map it to the
outputs you are interested and then then
you use all these optimization
techniques to your SN a parameter for
those those models so the second class
of model is going to be graphical model
so in graphical model you tend to model
more detailed information about the
relationship between these random
variables use the graph structure to
sort of capture conditional independence
structure between these variables and
then you're going to privatize this
graphical model whether potentials to
some kind of parameter and your learning
where the graphical model inference
procedures so in terms of the
scalability nowadays people are able to
scale this function approximation
approach to many many large scale
problems
millions and billions of data points and
if a graphical model it's less scalable
because it's unconstrained by this graph
structure you are your constraint to
operate according to the graph structure
but in terms of the the type of
structure you can incorporate into the
model graph model is very good you can
actually take lots of prior information
and encoding this graph structure and in
the computation according to that so so
the hope is
we want to somehow use lots of prior
knowledge and but being a metal scallop
or so so I am able to sort of look into
something here okay
which can combine graphical model and
then function mapping approach hopefully
giving a large amount of data you're
that kind of algorithm can scale to that
region while at the same time
cooperating this prior knowledge can
reduce the amount of data you needed to
get some very complex or learn some very
complicated phenomenon okay so the the
type of technique I'm I'm looking into
is going to be something called
embedding so that the sort of the before
I go into the details of this approach I
will give you just some schematic
illustration of what is embedding
produce doing as a workflow so typically
you look at a problem it has some
structures so you're actually going to
think about there's a little more of a
model graphical model behind this type
of problem but you are not going to
actually learning in the traditional
graphical model way going studies
inference and and learning the potential
instead you're going to look into the
actually the infant's algorithm for
graphical model and directly privatize
those inference algorithms as somethin
on your functions and then once you have
this nonlinear function you're able to
run some kind of a representative vector
or embedding for each one is node in the
graph and then you use it afterwards to
form some kind of a prediction or
classify for some kind generative model
or you can learn these type of embedded
hours and using reinforcement learning
so before I can go into detail just
going to give you three examples three
sets of examples where you actually need
to incorporate both structure
information and and use a nonlinear
function mapping approach together so
the first set of example is this type of
example when you try to actually build
some kind of classifier or regression
now with infrastructure data what do I
mean by structure data each one is input
data point is going to be a graph
structure by itself for instance this is
a problem from material science and
computational biology where each one is
data point is going to be a molecule
okay so it's not your work Tori format
to start with and each one of these data
points it's going to attach with a label
how effective it is to converse and
enter energy how effective jug it is
okay so you want to build some kind of
classifier regression now when I'm
taking these graph as input
put some number so you have to come up
with some rect orientation to start with
so this is another problem in social
network when you try to predict the
viral whether a particular cascade or
information spread is going to be right
or not based on the earliest spreading
pattern okay so each one is input again
it's going to be a graph structure at
the early spreading pattern of the
Cascade you want to predict what it's
going to be losing a million people
after one week so it's again structure
to the none number a regression to have
a problem but you don't get these
vectorial representation for the
structures that words so there are many
problems actually you will have
structure and you want to do some kind
calcification regression for instance
NLP has a lot of structure and now this
way as you go to computer programming
language and try to analyze the program
you can actually represent program as a
graph and you want to classify maybe
that particular piece of program is
malicious or not based on just these
graph representation of the program so
there's a lot of problem actually you
you are provided with each data point as
a graph and you want to learn something
regression or classification algorithm
based on that okay so one actually very
simple approach which has already been
addressed in Kalama the community is is
designing some kind of kernels between
these structures and and then work from
that point so once in where simple
kernel is going to be actually look at
some representation called bag of
structures so many of you might be
familiar with bag of words
representation that's taking the
documents and count a number occurrence
of some key words in the documents back
of structure is going to essentially
have a dictionary of small structures
such as a tree of you know def one and
many different type of trees are def one
maybe the note is different and you can
look at a tree of death to okay that
that's another word carrying or
dictionary you just count the number of
occurrences or these sub structures in
your in your data points and then your
then you have this feature vector and
you do regression whatever so we have
these 2.3 million data sets with the too
much 3 million molecules and you want to
make a prediction how effective the
particular molecule for converting
sunlight to energy so if you actually
use this type of bag of structure type
of approach to describe the molecule you
will find that you get the state of our
performance you will get two
roughly a billion parameters again so
you will have need to have that high
dimensional representation because level
two is not enough you need to go to
level three and four or five six and
then because this combinatorial
structure the node can be different the
connectivity structure of the graph can
be different you get a very very high
dimensional okay regression problem so
of course you can do something smarter
actually use some idea from theoretic
computer science to design the better
algorithm for extracting feature from
this graph structure one particular
approach is actually based on quasi
graph isomorphism check so there's these
graphs graph isomorphism chequered
whitefella lemon algorithm actually what
you do you compress your presentation as
you go so these are when is I to ative
it's going to be something like this so
first each node has a pipe right
different type of Acton's you first have
a hash function you hash the type into
some fixed of dimensional vector HR so
you're going to do that for each one is
node in a graph I'm just describing
checking the feature for each one of
these graph and then then each one is
graph has its own representation okay so
first you have a recommendation for each
node in a graph and then then they
always are going to iterate so each one
is know is going to be updated based on
the neighboring hash values so you're
actually going to get we get the
neighboring hash value in some way is
for instance just sum together somehow
and then incorporate a current node hash
value yeah you have rehash again okay so
you do something combination and then
rehash it again you keep the
representation for each node fixed but
now you're aggregating information for
neighbors okay you do this for each one
is node you finish one sweep you go to
the second sweep okay
so after you finish T iterations then
each one is no it's going to have a
fixed dimensional vector you aggregate
it somehow in the end to describe the
entire structure so by doing this you
can you can you can fix the dimension
for the entire structure right for
instance I can pick something much
smaller maybe maybe 10 times or 100
times smaller than this and in the end I
get its feature vector jewelry question
so you will find that if you use hash
function although it has compressed a
representation a lot but in order to get
the comparable performance with this you
still need
this number of hash keys okay so still
very high-dimensional regression problem
and in this case it's a denser
representation actually this type of
graphical model thinking and betting
approach you can actually reduce the
essentially model file size by another
thousand fold okay you will get a very
small model but matching the performance
and sometimes even better performance
than these algorithm okay so this is
once in our we're embedding can help
your justiça reducing the model sizes
and but being able to get a state of a
prediction this is the the case where
you're just embedding for structured
data the second case is this familiar
setting for recommendation systems okay
and this is a sort of the typical where
data is being recorded in all this
recommendation system people go online
and buy some items and actually the DD
the interaction between people in light
is not static okay it's actually the
citizen recording the precise temporal
information about when the user is
interacting with a particular item so
you're not just having you know the
rating of the user to the item you also
has pre-signed timestamps information
okay but typically when you try to model
this type of recommendations prone
problem try to make a prediction about
some of the item that the user hasn't
been interacting with you will you will
sort of have a model of matrix
factorization you motor this thing and
so on aways on the temporal information
and motor areas a sparse matrix like
this or user item of course there's also
extension to tensor vectorization you
have additional tie axis but you need to
discretize the time let's say you just
use this model okay and typical way of
doing it is trying to factorize these
sparse matrix of user item direction
into a user factor and item factor each
row these use of factor is going to
correspond to one user in each column is
going to correspond to one item in some
sense you try to learn some kind of
embedding of the user and also the items
such that the inner product can make a
very good prediction about whether
they're going to interact or not so if
you look at these algorithm for
performing matrix factorization there
were simple is alternating these square
minimization okay so essentially what
you are going to do is that actually
you're going to update this embedding
for the
user no the according the graph
structure so for instance what you're
going to do is each one is row is going
to correspond into the feature embedding
for the user you're going to initialize
them okay for each one is a user know
the Nitin note and that the user know is
going to be updated according to a local
minimization problem so it's a least
square minimization is the rating
corresponding to these entries here when
you try to update it in benefit
particular user I here and you're
solving optimization problem where you
actually just aggregate information from
the neighboring item the user has been
interacting with and similarly for the
updating of the item feature you're
actually just using the embedding for
the users this item has been interacting
with mmm and if you actually solve this
optimization problem it can be written
as a closed form it's a linear
aggregation of embedding of the user
neighbors so essentially when you try to
update a user embedding you're going to
look at the item he has interact with
and do some kind of aggregation okay so
when you actually try to update ITIN
feature you're going to aggregate a user
who has already interact with that
pedigree item and do somewhere as simple
ok linear aggregation so because the
choice of model you end up with this
linear updating the update here and you
keep iterating propagating along this
graph structure and you has throw away
the temporal information order
information of these interactions and if
you do with embedding actually you can
get a much better result okay and you
can reduce in this case the prediction
particular data set I'll read it you can
reduce a prediction error for return
time so when the user is coming back to
interact particular item by threefold
again using this embedding so the third
scenario is more of your writing
computer times for those here is there
was an approximation I wasn't for this
commentar optimization problem over
graph structure so actually this problem
self again again in those social network
companies for instance you if you want
to do inference maximization you're
solving something like a set cover or
vertex cover problem and many other
problems are also being solved in the
social network company in those cases
the network structures are of course not
static so people are you know checking
online and off all the time and there
may be presence absence of some edges
it's actually a family or distribution
of this graph structure you're trying to
solve a family of a comment or
optimization problem so let's just look
at a particular problem or vertex cover
problem and look at the one
approximation algorithm which has a
approximation guarantee this is the
approximation
I was with to approximation guarantee
for meaning where this cover so
essentially in this case you are
provided with this network structure you
try to pick a small number unknown as
possible such that every each one is
edge at least one n has been been
selected okay so one one way simple
output is going to use the degree
information essentially you're going to
look at each edge in this case it's
actually packing you can also pick the
node but there's no guarantee but
there's a simple one where you look at
the edge and look at two end of the edge
and sum together the degree of the two
ends so you're going to select those
edges with with highest total degree so
once you select these nose you detect it
I will remove it from the graph view
stuff on the remaining graph and just
keep using this algorithm so this is a
very simple heuristic the evidence step
is essentially it's also going to be
something some propagation process
essentially just think about each node
has a tag 0 here and it's actually
aggregating some together count the
number of zeros in the neighboring nodes
ok essentially doing that simple linear
operation if you take the de Graaff like
this so but this is a simple linear
function again ok and then it's designed
beforehand so in the embedding word
we're going to actually learn these type
of operations and then we're embedding
actually you can learn something much
better some algorithm which can produce
approximation ratio roughly equal to 1
compared to optimal over cost of our
graphs so this is something that the
embedding can do for you so um so yeah
so what's the training data for this so
there's some network generators either
generating a scale-free network or
random graph you can't return many many
instances use that to change your
algorithm know what
to training so we tried both what do you
give it a strain Chinese the guav the
every time the sample graph yeah that's
it no level yeah
so you actually actually at any point in
time you have learned elbows and you
execute it and see its performance and
then you're going to update a parameter
of their Lundell where according to its
performance so there's no explicit C
supervision okay what are the parameters
telling it to do the project ality I
wasn't to pick things for instance
either you try to parameterize a greedy
algorithm and then it's trying to learn
some way to score these edges and nose
but you need to learn the very good way
discordant so once you have that then
you can do a query with like this
there's some features yeah that's right
yeah maybe also the greedy algorithm
produces something like that I mean the
two apart summation is not greedy but it
might be the case that on the graph on
this particular driving produces a much
better solution so this is the on the
Padilla graph that's why two
approximation is actually doing better
than two again it's one point something
okay and then all these actually I
wasn't it does much better in practice
than the guarantee okay but you can't
you learn something for a particular
distribution problem something even
better
okay okay so um yeah
what is being evaluated you say that you
generate a score function for each node
yeah how what would what is given is
that okay so the goal is to pick a small
number of node as possible so in the end
you can look at a solution how many
nodes has been picked and all the edges
are being covered if algorithm is
picking a very small number nose and
make sure that the end of the edge very
edge at least one end is being covered
then it's good so finally we'll examine
the defined yeah the final score is the
size of waters cover how many nose you
pick in this graph yeah yeah okay so you
judge you is some how long algorithm
which can in a lower minimize that okay
so actually of all this problems I just
presented all this family of problems
three family or problem presented
actually the common structure is
algorithm is actually you can think
about is a composition of a set of
manually designed operations in this
predicates it's actually near operations
okay so the question is whether we can
think about this out within a unifying
framework and come up with a better
prime translation for this algorithm and
somehow think about it from a different
angle and also see the limitation of
this railways and it learns something
better based on data okay that's the
sort of the question I asked
so embedding is going to be something
like this okay so for this finding
Bennett framework actually just start
with a modern your problem we're
actually going to think about there's a
graphical model behind it so initially
you it's not clear why wise graphical
model thinking is good but I'm going to
show you example what I thinking in the
graphical model way is actually it's
good idea okay so for instance in these
molecule case so you have such a
molecule and each know is going to
correspond to one Acton's and the edge
is going to correspond to or into the
chemical bombs and you might have
additional information attached to each
one is no such as the type of the atoms
maybe you have some energy information
like type of chemical bombs but what we
are going to do is we're going to
represent is something called latent
verbal model and you're going to
introduce an additional variable later
garbage
corresponding to each one is no the
original structure okay and the
connectivity between these late and
wearable is going to be all the
connected condition independence
structure is going to be the same as the
input structure of course you can also
design something more complicated based
on the prior knowledge so typically in
graphical model thinking if you want to
assign the probability or density to the
set of particular configuration to this
random variable you need something like
a potential function so essentially in
this case if you describe this
particular datum were using something
called a pairwise Markov random view
then in the parameter is some kind of
potential the compatibility between the
hidden variable and the observed ones X
here and also between these hidden
variables once you have this potential
function then you can actually compute
some kind John probability of these
latent variable joint density of these
latent variables okay yeah this is the
graphical model and depending on how you
normalize the thing you can get a
conditional model or just joint model
okay suppose we are having a conditional
model like this okay with this graphical
model then actually there's a very good
way of thinking about how do you
actually describe the particular node as
you situate in the entire graph how do
you agree gate information cross this
graph to describe how important is that
particular node actually very simple
quantity to actually think about the
information that importance or type of
informations present empirical notes are
just computing the posterior
distribution of that knows given all the
rest so if there multiple rating were
present you just somehow or other ones
okay it's a big summation a big
computation here according to the graph
structure and it computers the marginal
or the posterior of a particular node
given the rest okay so in the next slide
I have the algorithm particular
obviously efficiently I wouldn't
approximate this computation so you will
see at that point is getting even more
clear this computation or getting the
posterior is actually aggregating
information across the graph structure
okay yeah what's the addition of the
monsieur jerry is trying to aggregate
information according to graph structure
and propagate sort of distant
information to a node here and trying to
describe how important it is in the
graph it's some kind of information of
the node and describing how it is
situated in a graph structure and then
you know how different topology changed
you know the the information that
particular node okay so when you see the
algorithms become more clear okay
so one simple algorithm so once you have
this posterior distribution you suppose
it's continuous variable you can just
describe it with some kind of sufficient
statistics and then you get a finite
dimensional vector you can use that to
vector from that point on to to do many
things so but the way we look at this
particular algorithm for computing or
approximating is posterior the
propagation or information education
process become unclear so one simple out
ways and to actually do this by the way
if you try to compute the posterior if
the graph structure is not a tree it's
actually a gif accommodation problem you
need to somehow explanation number of
possibilities and if it is treated and
it's simple but the typically we are
handling the cases when you've not tree
then what you're going to do is you're
going to make approximation that
proximation is going to say that I'm
going to approximate a joint posterior
of all these latent variable by the
product of a bunch of turns which is Q
for a product distribution Q so you're
going to compute this Q in the auditory
fashion okay
this particular complication called the
mean fewer words and it's going to
initialize each node by some kind of
posterior distribution okay and then
you're going to iterate according to the
graph structure so for every node you're
actually going to aggregate the
intermediate results for other notes
according to this formula so this
formula that the actual form that is no
important but what's important is
actually the dependency structure so
it's going to take the node potential
and also the edge potential between the
particular node of interest and its
neighbors and it's going to aggregate
all its neighboring intermediate
solution for instance if I ensure the
computing the posterior for updating
posterior for q1 I'm going to look at
the current solution for Q 2 Q 5 Q 6
which are neighbors of q2 q1 and
and aggregate it okay so the Padilla
operation is something like this okay
it's a nonlinear operation yeah and then
the dependence structure is something
like this so it's some operation and
looking at the observation X I and that
particular node and also look at all the
neighboring node of I and aggregate it
okay this is some nonlinear operations
and then these Qi is the distribution
density non- normalized to one aware
often we also work with a version
without normalization okay this is the
propagation so you're propagating
information according to the graph
structure if you run white one nitration
you're aggregating information from
immediate neighbors and if you're
running two iteration you're aggregating
neighbors of the neighbor information
and the aggregation is according to the
graph structure and also according to
those designed or learned potential
function on edge here okay so that such
a propagation process if you think about
the pattern of this algorithm it's
actually very similar to the you know
these graph feature extraction algorithm
where is similar to this recommendation
system that very similar to these
combinatorial optimization ristic we
designed by hand okay so this is the
similarity there okay so now we're going
to essentially instead of doing you know
the traditional graphical model learning
actually you actually need to run this
algorithm in order to learn the
parameter you want to learn this it's a
chicken-egg problem okay in order do
this inference computing process here
you have to have these parameters
potentials these parameters here and in
order to learn is primary you have to
run run this algorithm first and even
after you finish learning these
parameters this step is also quite
complicated first you have to do an
integration and prod about this thing
okay so we're going to actually think
about in a from a different angle we're
going to have a different representation
for these distributions and we are going
to actually also read permit rise these
updates and some kind of nonlinear
function okay that's the key idea so how
do we represent this distribution we're
going to use vector space embedding idea
for representing distributions what is
embedding embedding essentially is
suppose you have some continuous random
variable even want one dimensional
it has a different density okay these
are 2d densities and then you're going
to actually consider this type of
mapping mapping these density to a
vector space by applying some kind of no
new transformation in this random
variable edge and take expectation with
respect to that density you are working
with so actually we have done lots of
work on these embedding space if you're
able to pick a flexible reach enough
known in your mapping so this vectorial
space representation is actually not
losing any information about the density
itself so it's a number major way to
describing in some sense the the density
okay with with alternative privatization
okay so for instance you can use the
kernels and the corresponding mapping
for the kernels and the expected value
of that feature mass is going to be
injective yeah so it's a sufficient
statistics for the original density and
it's not losing information that means
that if you have some operations which
applies to the original density and you
can do the same on the embedding but
using alternative operation okay so you
can think about that if I have a region
of vector representation for my density
and then I can just keep operating on
that vector representation and get
something as a result corresponding to
the results of these operations on the
density itself okay so this is for
lumber but of course you can generalize
the idea to yeah
embedding could you say align what
embedding is referred representing what
of the description for instance this is
example if you pick this nonlinear
mapping as X X square X cubic so it's
capturing the you know second order
moment further Ottoman higher order
moments right so sometimes when you pick
a kind of function corresponding non Li
transformation the feature space is
going to be infinite dimension actually
you can capture infinite dimensional
kind of high order moments but in this
talking and the focus on your net
parameter ization you actually fix the
dimension but not in your future okay
and learn that so you can generalize
this embedding idea to just you know
pair of cheaply or verb or even more
variables so you're going to will joint
density and
density of a pair three wearables some
kind of vector tensor or matrix or
tending high dimensional space or
potentially infinite dimensional space
and you can actually design for the two
sample tests comparing to a distribution
based on this representation you get
very simple formula you can actually
design team benders measurement things
like this minimizing the other tests and
use them for as a replacement for mutual
information for carrier divergence for
doing a bunch of things and then
recently I have been sort of trying to
combine this embedding idea with
graphical model and especially if you
look at a graphical model in operations
the key operation is going to actually
be some rule prod around Bayes rule you
can actually get a [ __ ]
representation for all these rules using
this embedded representation okay and
you will be able to actually operate
graphical model and do these influenced
hours and purely using these kind of
environments in tation so we had
something like spectral algorithm for a
hidden Markov model and it is embedding
an idea and we have also canalis
embedded version kind of BP and things
like this okay
but today essentially we are going to
impact these mean few hours and other
influences I was on from graphical model
so now instead of thinking about
representing approximating these
posterior distribution for this later
memorable as the density you are going
to represent it in this embedded space
Mui okay
you are also going to keep updating
these new eyes instead of the original
density so essentially you are going to
initialize each one is known as a vector
representation and you are going to
agree get it
these vector representation according to
nonlinear mapping okay so that's it okay
and you're not going to actually hand
design it's nonlinear mapping but you're
gonna have parameterize it as something
on your function and then learn it
afterwards so once you have these
suppose you already have these nonlinear
mapping and this outputting essentially
is composing these nonlinear operations
and in the end you derive some kind of
after you have a few iterations you
arrive some kind of vector
representation for each one is node you
can take these vector representation of
the node to do lots of downstream tasks
you can actually define some function on
individual node or pair of node for
predicting whether a pair
no it's going to interact what not I'll
take the entire back of vector
representation and do something okay so
you can actually use in the end
supervisor a general model or informal
learning to change these parameters in
this nonlinear are nonlinear mapping
okay so essentially this is a specific
parameter ization but it's nonlinear
mapping okay you can pick any universal
function approximator if you were a
powerful update step and in the end
you're your algorithm becomes a
composition of these non linear mappings
you try to chain it so by the specific
parameters I think is going to be
something like this so against you you
know you sense you taking what happened
vector instead for the node you have a
matrix transform in it and you're going
to aggregate these neighboring
embeddings maybe some weighting barriers
well use annotation mechanism and
transform it with another matrix and in
the end you have this non-linearity
applied and wisely to produce the new
embedding so it's more like one layer
hidden one hidden layer new nuts okay
yeah yeah okay because but because you
have this many steps of algorithm it's
becoming some kind of deep architecture
okay so you have a vector for each node
on your gara but when you embedded there
is some permutation group acting on that
right two of those guys you may have
different permutation so how would you
yeah so so so when you aggregate that's
why this is one choice I'm just
something together so that's in some
sense the environment to the permutation
or the ordering of the nodes but there's
a way to actually use the outer product
tensor and you have a tensor primate
that reduce it to a number or vector so
that there's some choice is there we
haven't fully explored yeah I fi some
kind of weights it's a number so you can
actually this is again you can think
about it's a function which takes the MU
I embedding and have as one additional
parameter and reduce it to a number
that's going to be the weights so you do
a waiting area
so that's called a potential mechanism
deep learning so you can do that yeah so
somehow you learn to aggregate it you
can also do that
okay it's about better yeah okay but
your goal would be to take some
permutation and variant aggregation yeah
yeah yeah so if you don't use these
weights then then the natural thing is
to just come up with some kind of
permutation where a privatization of
this step one simple way is to do out
the product yeah keep doing other
product for these neighbor imbalance
then you reduce it with the tensor which
is a symmetric tensor parameter which is
symmetric okay so okay so by doing this
actually in some sense you're switching
the wheel before one is designed to non
your function estimation problem okay
it's something like a paradigm shift you
think about your algorithm as structure
composition of unknown e operations okay
the structure is determined by the
algorithm template you pick and the bet
that you delegate those privatization on
the steps to our learning okay so
essentially if you you think about is
the inference algorithm as computing
something okay taking the graph input
and computing something so the graph
c'mon inference noggin is a restrictive
family of functions because you have to
compute according to the learned
potential okay it's not the most
flexible function you can use so but you
directly privatize these inference
outwards and you pick for the graphical
models not in your mapping so it's more
flexible privatization for each step in
the end that you can actually get
something more flexible but the but it's
also less flexible than fully connecting
neural nets and those things doesn't
consider the structure okay so in some
sense if you've given me amount of data
so these this approach aggregate using
the structure information actually can
share more information out of the data
okay so the benefit of thinking about it
in a graphical model sense is there's so
many other ways of aggregating
information calling the structure and
each one is the inference I was in
graphical models suggest a new algorithm
template and then you can actually get
something different so this is another
one better one that inference now going
for graphical model inference aggregate
information across the graph structure
it's going to be belief propagation so
instead of actually approximating the
joint posterior as the product
distribution you actually privatized
some kind of messages for each one is
edge you are going to actually have two
nonlinear function on negative functions
associated you can think about two
densities associated with each one is
edge so it's going to be passing forward
and backward and then you again it's
actually always and you initialize these
messages and then you're going to update
it according to some kind of algorithm
steps
so these updates step is going to exact
for is no important it's going to
depending on an original graphical mode
parameter ization but essentially in for
instance if you want to pass update a
message from h1 to h2 so what you're
getting is you have to aggregate all
these messages sending to h1 and then
you're going to update its message from
h1 - to okay so is this type of
dependence structure for these
particular algorithm yeah so you have X
I here
all the neighbors of our acceptor
destination node J you're going to
aggregate it according to some known
operations so at this point you might
already know how to guess what's going
to happen so it's difficult to do in the
original graph kamala way so instead
we're going to privatize this nonlinear
mapping ok and some nonlinear function
only new nets and Chaney in the end ok
essentially you get another day out
region for aggregating information it is
this embedded belief propagation there
are many many other graphical model
inference algorithms such as generalized
min few which cost a bunch of nodes
together and do min few and generalize
belief propagation you also do the cost
of nodes and doing its propagation there
many other are the higher order
Corrections ok yeah integration is being
replaced by a single nonlinear mapping
it's a vector output yeah so you always
keep the same dimension vector R ah it's
possible maybe Peter knows how this
representation can happen yeah yeah ok
so essentially you're going to have this
mu IJ for your Chinese edge and you're
going to update is mu IJ according to
this nonlinear mapping and once you
finish your iterations may be converge
to some kind of fixed point or you just
chunk area that
some tea isolations and then you can
actually produce a note embedding by
aggregating all these neighbors of the
particular node so this is like
computing the marginal in the end using
this PDF baggage okay so at this point
once you have the embedding you can do
many other things such as this okay
so it's the same but but there's so many
out I wouldn't template you can use
thinking in the graph come all the way
so essentially this is yet another
function space essentially previously
when you china design this new algorithm
on machine learning right first you had
the thing about model the model that
think very hard the pics on features now
you have two additional tools to think
about designing outwards why is this
graphical model thinking and otherwise
the function approximation thinking from
graphical model thinking you get the
very principle way of incorporating
these prior knowledge and price
structuring your problem and then you
also have all these family of choices or
variation or inference algorithm for you
as the element template and then from
that point on you you privatize your
inference that with the steps as unknown
in function now the entire element
becomes some composition learning
functions and then you can use these
theory from learning function
approximation such as how flexible is
that representation how do you analyze
the complexity of their function class
and how do you actually study the
stability of these this type of a model
of course there's this fundamental
problem is in the end of learning is
going to be non convex optimization if
you able to solve that kind of problem
then you get a very good explanation of
about or guarantee for these learning
algorithms okay so let's just sort of
graduate is so the big picture of the
the framework so essentially you look at
a problem that some structure it may be
that the input data point itself is a
structure maybe it's operating on some
graph structure and and then you sort of
conceptually assign the graphical model
for that particular problem structure it
might be different for different data
point yeah and but you're not going to
lay in a traditional way learning the
potential and perform inference use that
as sort of a template for designing
graphical model inference algorithm and
you're going to privatize
these infants algorithm steps this
nonlinear function well keep working on
the embedding representation okay in the
end you get some kind representation for
each one is node in the in the graph
maybe even also the edge for each one is
graph you compose your function in the
end to make a prediction for your final
target okay so let's just use this
framework and these three sets of
problems I just mentioned and see what
you will get so the first problem is a
prediction for structure problem so the
input is going to be molecule each
molecule is going to correspond to a
different topological structure and then
but you're going to privatize this mule
or beautiful Gatien using these this
embedding idea in this case the
nonlinear mapping is share cross all
this update and share cross or this data
point okay you have a common set of
parameter and apply a cross again you
reduce that otherwise you have lots of
parameters so once you have these
assumptions the embedding for each one
is node so in order to describe in this
case try to extract the feature for the
entire molecule right so you are going
to aggregate it use the entire back to
define something so what a simple thing
is again you just sum them together in
one into the permutation okay and then
you get a fixed vector representation
for the entire structure and then you
have a vector here linking that the
embedment attention to some one number
or set of numbers your own regression so
so in this case this V is some primary
need to learn and then the mule you want
to produce mule you have this pregnant
choice I wasn't steps you need to learn
okay those are primary also need to
learn so essentially it's just like a
diploid architecture yeah so in this
pipeline I get around 0.2 or 3 I'm
trying to understand so the graphical
model so that I'm embedding it's some
kind of a low dimensional representation
is a dimension representation of the
posterior of a pelican note yeah
not of the primary no not the parameters
the posterior it's like your chart you
actually represent the at any point the
intermediate result of approximately
posterior you keep maintaining that one
yeah so by privatizing as some kind of
non your mapping you try to learn some
low dimensional nonlinear mapping which
preserve sort of the information yeah so
the analog of belief propagation here is
a parametrized a bunch of pro-choice
mappings I guess and you say that's
right so common across all of it yeah so
how does that work when you have
different radical yeah so when you have
different graph structure so you
essentially the the neighborhood
structure is kind of different and the
number of vector unit area is different
but very simple thing you do here is you
share the parameter so this w1 w2 here
this is describing update for particular
know the neighbor who can be different
you you share it okay just such a simple
model share them it's like a in graph
kamala sense a template model of this
the changes when you go from graphic
that's right that's right
so once you learned and then when you
apply that new graph it's the same set
of parameter it's just these
neighborhoods kinda different for you
know yeah okay and that's how you get
hugely compressed representation in the
bottom they also let this that's that's
the benefit you get okay um yeah um the
Meuse are going to be different for
every each no yeah each node in each
graph yeah that's right so the
parameters that are shared that's why
that's right exactly the parameter to
update is Meuse are share cross okay
that's how you get huge compress the
model yeah yeah how what about the
initial parameterization that you
from you how does that affect your final
yeah doesn't affect that much we
initialize as zero and then you just I
trade after some time actually it's
converging to something yeah so after
actually a few a step a duration it
doesn't change that much actually that's
what we saw in practice so typically
actually given such a graph or even the
bigger graph right wages less than ten
that steps okay and okay so this is when
the result when you apply this type of
technique to extracting feature for
these two point three million molecular
data sets and in here essentially we're
comparing to these these approach based
on you know hashed representation of
this back of structure so this called
awhile slammer was fellow lemon
algorithm and then but you still need to
use very high dimensional hash fir have
many many hash keys so to get these
performance over 0.095 it's like a four
percent relative error so it's almost
predicting very accurately the the
efficiency of converting sunlight energy
so then if you have such a fast way
making a prediction you don't need to
actually synthesize it first okay it's
first make a prediction and if it's
promising then you you go and synthesize
that is not your molecule and then of
course you can reduce the size of this
hash hash key okay you can use fewer
fewer number of hashes so as you it's
like a you can think about these hashes
it's doing some kind of random
projection okay so you as you use a less
and less random projection the
performance just degrees and then when
you use a for instance one minim
parameters using this hash approach then
you get 0.28 but using this learned
embedding you'll end up with something
with a small privatization and and the
the performance is actually
state-of-the-art and this means if you
keep propagation approach supposedly is
slightly better infant cell going to
actually give you something better
okay performance in the end with the
same number of iteration over the graph
that's a way of aggregating information
over the graph structure and they
actually give you something better and
much faster okay so this is some benefit
you can get so the second problem
instead of a recommendation problem you
know people are interacting with iTunes
so it's a bipartite graph actually
evolving over time so we are not going
to model it as some kind of matrix spots
matching factorize it so we're going to
model it as a latent variable model
especially in the later world model
which is evolving over time okay you're
going to unload this bipartite graph
okay how do you unroll this so
essentially suppose you have two users
in one item and every time when its
particular user interact with the item
I'm going to introduce a new pair of
those one corresponding to that user one
correspond to item I'm going to connect
this item with the previous user no.19
node the same thing for the user the
next I see a different pair of
interaction I'm going to create two new
notes and in connecting these these I
don't know where the user and user with
item you have this cross okay so
essentially you have these graph
structure which is keep growing as you
see more interactions okay so the hope
is to capture that maybe these feature
embed infla know is changing evolving
okay as you see more interaction between
the user item you want to capture their
evolution perspective of the users
feature so if you have such a problem
structure so then you map it to a
blatant horrible model contract you're
thinking about you have such a late
model model you're going to essentially
introduce one hidden node for each one
is an origin note in a graph and the
connectivity between these hidden nodes
exactly the same as the the problem
structure and then basically hidden no
you're going to generate a pair of that
this is the user in that notice the I
think II don't know they're going to
generate an interaction these observed
information is going to be the time of
the interaction the rating and other
context things like this okay you have
such a graphical model if you think
about from the original graphical model
point where you have to learn these edge
potential research potential things like
this okay so but we are going to embed
in this case so called futuring outwards
and forward propagation okay essentially
you're going to do something like this
then
operation you're going to have is
initially the users profile information
you have one nonlinear mapping which
produced embedding for each one is know
initially and then every time there's
interaction you're going to have these
these these updates which takes the
interaction feature and the previous
user vision item feature and profiles on
only update and produce the new one okay
it's actually going to correspond to the
fewer filtering hours and in hidden
Markov model but in this case of a graph
you just trying to predict something in
the future you don't want to go back
okay you want to predict something in
the future with this one and some of it
what I to know you're going to do the
same type of update maybe with different
privatization for the nonlinear mapping
and any point in time you will have some
kind embedding representation for each
one is node each one is item then you
can make use of pair of them to you know
predict whether they're going to wrecked
or not so most specifically yeah you
have this unrolled interaction graph
between a user Nitin you have
conceptually associated this latent
Weber model and then the others and
you're going to pick is full of
filtering and inference in graph Kamado
and then in point in time you have these
embedding representation depending on
the parameterization you have and you
can at any point in time you can take a
pair of embedding from the user and node
and in a component function and predict
something you are interested for
instance you can actually try to predict
the time of them direction so you're
going to actually make a density model
out of it you're going to take one
embedding for a node
take one value for the item you compute
these there in the prodigal they are so
the larger they are the more likely
they're going to interact it is smaller
that's less likely to interact in the
near future and then with this alpha
prime air you can make a real a
distribution okay to describe the time
of the interaction and use max market
who would do it to fee to the actual
sequence of interaction ty observed or
actual sequence of interaction feature
observed so you can change with maximum
I can whole you can chain it with other
divergences okay and then you get very
good reason that's how you get is a
model embedding model with much better
prediction in terms of the which one is
the next item to interact with what is
the time on the interaction so in
particular when you try to predict
and interaction compared to those matrix
factorization based approach it's like a
three times better okay
so but the instead of this number
actually I'm going to show you something
what is learned by these embedded
algorithm actually you can look at those
cases where these embedded hours is
producing more accurate prediction than
traditional matrix factorization
approach and see what kind of pattern
has been captured so I'm going to talk
about related data set instead of ready
data so rbtv data is that this is
something we call the temporal knowledge
graph completion problem and but the
nature of the problem are exactly the
same in this case the knowledge graph is
going to consist of entities the subject
object a foreign relationship it's a
directed graph and instead of by
Paraguay but this information is
restricted for the news article
essentially you have this graph which is
changing over time as new thing happen
in the world you get a new pair of edges
maybe new nose being added to the system
as well so you have such a moment graph
but if you just think about it using
these embedding wheel you can unroll
this temporal graph as well you get
embedding for each one snow at any point
in time you can make a prediction when
the pair of nodes going to have some
interaction or not okay so we're going
to look at those cases where the
embedding should produce very actual
prediction but the major factorization
is not doing well this is a particular
example of this embedding doing the
reasoning okay over time so so there's a
node called Cairo here see and there's
another knows nor Croatia here okay and
then all these red edges are going to
indicate negative type of interaction
okay
the green wire is going to be positive
interaction so at some point in time in
the past May the 6 March the 6th you
have this negative interaction between
this no and no there and then there's a
positive interaction between these
Manchester and a Croatia here ok and
then at some point in future there's a
negative interaction between these these
red no and and there's no you're doing
with the classifier or what so instead
and Graham's pacifier even didn't know
the information yes name of friendly or
what else binary prediction or
particular time or pretendin time of the
interaction
but it's automated with some bag of
Andhra features how are you doing the
feature is okay so the feature is
essentially also learned in the network
right so we have embedding for each one
is node so we have for each one is node
in the network we have embedding so we
are going to take the embedding and then
doing the product between these
embeddings and see how how comparable
they are how likely they are to interact
and that's going to give you a
prediction of when they're going to
interact no but a positive negative that
was a positive interaction or negative
so okay there's additional type
information you can cooperate it into
this prediction it's like multi-class
classification so those those are
predictions or yeah so these are the
predictions correctly and then you also
discover it in the in the data set
that's actually the interaction okay so
so there are some differences in the
predicted time okay that the areas were
small so I picked this example right the
solid edges are data the solid data's
are past data okay you want to predict a
future so in future how do you get
somebody threatened somebody or somebody
assaulted so it's just collected from
the news you keep seeing this thing
evolving over time you condition you on
the past or the Sony edges are the past
yes yeah MRP yeah sigh LP exactly yeah
okay so so so essentially condition all
these past and make a prediction we're
going to predict this and some point in
future and then you actually discover
this particular event in this data set
okay and the time is very close to your
predicted time it's just making this
okay so you have to the negative
possible path here reinforces sort of
this prediction not that so this data is
actually big and that they are not
dating
actually in such a such a you know
on-time fashion okay so this is a
non-example working from yeah maybe you
can do that so people try to actually
use this type of technique for reasoning
over you know something like financial
market things like this but but that's
your working progress
request here for the French election
yeah yeah yeah so hopefully that dataset
is up-to-date
yeah so this is another example right so
you have again all your solid edge or
something have been passed we are going
to predict conditional on the last time
point from this solid edge you want to
make a prediction about future
interaction okay so this dashed line is
the predicted some kind of positive
relationship you're actually discovering
the data set there's this relationship
and the time of that happening is where
it goes to the predicted time and then
in this case it's like it you know a
positive path a negative path it
reinforces this positive time between
them okay so this is an interesting
discovery this by modeling a problem
like this and the lower the embedding
approach you're actually capturing solid
is temporal reasoning which is not
possible by major factorization
yeah so it does when you're evaluated is
at any point in time right your Purdue
team we were predicting the future
events and you look at a tiny on your
prediction and you can look at what is
predicted presence or not you also look
at whether what is the time or the
prediction predicted time yeah I'm
saying you're predicting a bunch of
event for the future right some of them
come true some of them don't come yeah I
mean this one particularly yeah but do
you think that this is a more because
I'm just struggling so this is just
picking one example of many yeah and
this particular one is predicted not
present by major factorization of
approach okay by predicting present by
the by these many approach and much more
accurate so I'm just picking out those
examples right potentially it's able to
capture these sequence of temporal
reasoning better but there's no
guarantee or whatever yeah it's just an
interesting examples right so probably
the question is do you have any
statistical positive about the positive
rate and negative greater in this case
we actually model in density right so
actually you yeah so density and then
actually you can use also you can
Chinese so called the precision recall
curve you can have a threshold and then
we are doing better in that metric as
well right okay
we can also look at the expected time of
something happen and compare the error
that's how you compute is a return time
error thing how far along the graph you
have to go in time before you actually
make that kind of
addiction I mean because so we divide
the data into new something like you
know problem actually didn't look at
that file respect maybe one week or
something you will be able to be make a
prediction for that for for the future
events but as you go further into the
future that the prediction just stick
ways okay so the nice thing about this
is keeping cooperating some sense that
the history information yeah because we
know that density you actually get some
kind of insanity out of it okay you get
the entire distribution of the of the
time of potential interaction okay yeah
while claiming this model you left out
some of the you don't that the thing is
you always use the future to supervise
your path your yo-yo goes okay so it's
like I suppose I'm going to decide using
the first half of the year data okay as
my changing data set I'm going to have
my parameter every time within is a
first half year always predict the next
you know events in a sequencing that
that edge that you predicted was never
used in training it was never seen in
train yeah so for the test in time for a
second half a year we're going to make
prediction right okay yeah so this is
the case when you try to actually design
combinatorial optimization of a graph
structure so for this particular two
vectors vectors couple problem meaning
whether it's cover problem this is the
heuristic I mentioned earlier it's a
specific choice of no functions which
allows you to propagate information of
the graph and you only propagate one
step okay so that's a very simple sort
of outwards and you design by hand you
get this nice approximation now I'm
going to essentially privatize it with a
more flexible nonlinear aggregation
process and learn it okay so essentially
the way we changes our wizened is using
reinforcement learning so you have to
sort of wheel these algorithm steps as
some kind of making some decisions in
order to achieve a bigger goal okay the
bigger goal here is to minimize the
number of Picton nodes and to make sure
that for each pair of these edges
at least 1/n is being picked okay and
then if you look at the algorithm and
then you can think about every time you
pick a node you get a reward minus one
you penalize picking Manos okay and at
any point in time you have already the
set of pick notes that's going to be the
state to your Markov decision process
and then you have this scoring function
for each one is add your node in your
graph that's like the action value
functioning in the reinforcement line
setting and then you use greedy
procedure policy to pick actually the
action okay and after that you change
the state n you keep continue this okay
so we are essentially going to privatize
these action value function instead of
using this hand design the scrolling
function we're going to use this graph
embedding approach to probably get
information on the graph and learn
something better okay
so essentially you just take exactly
this graph embedding may be mean feel
may be beautification and at any point
in time you will get some kind of in
Beneful node and you're going to
actually look at how problem is in the
particular know compared to the entire
graph okay you're going to actually have
a function which not taking the original
embedding feature and then tie back and
compute something so there's some
privatization here you need to learn the
parameter using essentially
reinforcement techniques like kuelen in
particular okay let me just once you
landed always you just use query policy
to pick the nodes so let me just show
you the result quickly okay so we
actually general lots of graphs and we
can generate more and each one of these
dots here is going to correspond to one
problem okay so we have 200 problems and
then the cycle graph is actually not
very big 300 notes the reason why we
don't go to a bigger node graph is we
actually sleep likes to compute a proxy
for the global Optima we run simplex for
one hour and they use the solution as
the global Optima okay so simplex is
actually running in a interesting way
it's going to produce a result feasible
result one by one and in the middle you
can produce you know some first feasible
result solution but it's not so good in
terms of proximation quality second
result and the third result and for free
so you get very good
solution so if you use these learned
algorithm you're producing something
that they're almost as good as these
simplex running one hour but you run ten
times faster
okay so compared to these two
approximation algorithm and it's even
faster but it doesn't produce as good
approximation results okay so you can
actually throw away the graph structure
using something like your pointer
Network I and on the graph structure and
try to learn some kind of greediest EPs
and you're getting something here okay
the solution is not as good or it's
slightly faster so let me just show you
in the end the the algorithm whatever it
is learned okay it will actually be very
interesting look at what the action of
the algorithm so I have a three hours
and here one is language is in been
approach and Y is just picking node
greedily y is picking the edge quickly
okay so every time pick some notes from
the graph I'm going to remove it so the
graph getting spot since pasa
so whoever algorithm finish the graph
first is going to the best algorithm
okay the number of frames is going to
correspond to the number of steps in the
algorithm so let's just run it and
initially it looks like a note greedy is
doing pretty well okay so it's getting
very sparse graph but in the end these
embedding is catching it up okay
actually finish graph faster then these
degree and note degree you're designed
okay with the two approximation
guarantee for this case okay so the
reason is when we look at this pattern
the embedded projects you'll learn a
scrolling function to pick the nose not
just high degree ones they try to
somehow balance a little bit between how
fragmented is this graph you try to pick
relatively high degree note but keeping
the graph connected such that in the end
the algorithm has the potential to pick
another curve a lot of the graph but if
you this greedy always and you pick the
node it tend to fragment the graph in
the end you're forced to pick at least
one of this node in small fragments in
the end you're actually having a slower
algorithm okay so there's something
interesting so it is embedding approach
for learning algorithm potentially will
help you discover new type of algorithms
then you can analyze it they have some
guarantee okay so so let me just quickly
mention about the bigger theme in this
space so I've been talking about these
problems well
structure is relatively clear actually
in machine learning now there's a new
sort of feed trying to learn programs
okay special program with a perceptual
task you're learning to add things you
learn to solve things okay so what is
the more tasks here is for instance you
look at the your whiteboard there's a
two number written there sixty five and
twenty eight and then I give you the
answer ninety-three but I don't tell you
what operation it is and you also have
uncertainty and recognizing those digit
in the white bar okay so but I tell you
that operation has to be done according
to a particular structure always in
structure so I have to first recognize
the digits okay and then recognize
digital the first digit recognize the
the first digit here and then produce
some kind of using the recognized
digital produce on carries out which is
three and now I have to produce
something like a carry as well okay so
and and then the next iteration I'm
going to recognize the the digit in the
second column and then produce the
current resign and carry okay so in some
sense the algorithm itself is some kind
of graph structure okay
you have uncertainty here for predicting
the digit uncertainty here predicting
this digit not uncertainty here and then
you don't get supervision for this so
what you get supervision is in the end
this operation is going to give you
three here and in the end that operation
is going to give you now here and then
you have supervision here so all this
variable here doesn't have any
supervision so it's a sometime later
variable structure so the entire hours
in some way the variable structure it's
just providing some kind of weekly
supervised examples trying to learn
these these this intelligent task ok so
this type of problem can also be
addressed by this embedding framework
essentially so you can imagine they're
more complicated programs which is not
just these kind of very simple
feed-forward type of structure it might
be a graph structure each other solve a
problem if you have if-else and the wire
loop many many condition checks okay
so in the end I just like to summarize
essentially this in been differing work
trying to combine together the thinking
graph Kamado and nonlinear mapping so
you're going to take a problem structure
and concept you're thinking about the
presence of some kind of data model and
instead of learning in the tradition
graphical model sort of framework you're
going to privatize these large family of
embedding inference algorithm in
graphical model as a nonlinear mapping
so now the algorithm becomes a highly
structure the conversation a bunch of
small nonlinear operations so you're
going to learn these hours using
downstream supervisions or weeks
operations or reinforcement learning so
this is pretty much why I want to say I
think that many more things can be done
in this space thank you thank you for
the inference our algorithm case you
know using a one-lane neural net so
injury Seleucus things are iterative
example involving the vertex cover it's
surprising to approximate a key function
with a perceptron q function with
perception okay so the DDD yeah so the
so you also prime a child actually for
the initial two approximation it's just
running wire agen so for our case we
actually run multiple iterations so
you're actually looking at not just
immediate neighbors you're looking at
the neighbors of neighbors yeah the
after you have imitating better after a
few iterations you you then time it into
this Q function so that's why you can
learn something more flexible okay so
that's why the connectivity information
in some sense is not just local it's
maybe maybe longer range yeah you
learned that okay
instructor I think it is evaluation ones
would be just a great girl yeah exactly
that's actually my intuition for
understanding combination units I always
think about there's a Markov random
field with grid structure for for this
particular and image and then you run
generalize mean view you cross the notes
together and run convolution so in that
case you actually don't tie together all
these parameter for these these
iterative steps use different parameter
for each steps but you run fixed number
of steps yeah yeah that's right the same
thing here we couple across the entire
graph use the same set of parameter for
the entire graph and convolution like
using the same cell parameter across
this integral so recurrent nuna is like
a hidden Markov model and the primary
charge inference algorithm a futuring
it's the forward recon unit if you have
forward backward recon unit it's like a
few smoothing algorithm for the for
these graph Komodo
[Applause]